[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans science
clic
la théorie des cordes notre univers
contient de la matière qui lorsqu'on
zoome suffisamment est formé de
particules
il en existe différents types les
électrons les quark ou encore les
neutrinos les particules se déplace dans
l'univers et peuvent interagir en
s'échangeant d'autres particules la
force électromagnétique par exemple est
véhiculée par les changes de photons
toutes ces différentes particules
constituent ce qu'on appelle le modèle
standard
c'est à ce jour notre description
mathématiques la plus précise du monde
quantique
on y trouve deux grandes catégories de
particules les fermions qui constituent
la matière notamment et les bosons qui
contribue à décrire les interactions à
première vue on pourrait penser qu'il
s'agit de la théorie ultime que le
modèle standard permet de tout décrire
mais malheureusement il existe une autre
interaction qui échappent à ce modèle la
gravitation à grande échelle
on sait décrire la gravitation par la
relativité générale les astres courbe
l'espace-temps
ce qui attire les autres astres
comme pour les autres types
d'interactions on s'attendrait à ce que
la courbure de l'espace-temps soit
composé à l'échelle quantique de petites
particules décanta de courbure
d'espace-temps appelé gravitons mais
lorsqu'on essaye d'inclure le graviton
au modèle standard
les calculs donne des résultats absurde
avec des valeurs infinie auquel il est
impossible de remédier rien à faire on
ne parvient pas à décrire la gravité à
l'échelle quantique
c'est pour résoudre ce problème que les
physiciens recherche depuis plus d'un
demi-siècle de nouvelles théories dans
cette vidéo nous allons construire
ensemble l'une des approches les plus
prometteuses la théorie des cordes
[Musique]
l'idée de base est plutôt simple dans le
modèle standard
les particules sont décrites comme des
petits points sans dimension et on admet
que ces points n'ont pas tous les mêmes
propriétés pour expliquer qu'il existe
différents types de particules en
théorie des cordes
on va supposer que ceci n'est qu'une
approximation et qu'en réalité si l'on
zoome sur les particules elles sont
toutes formées d'un même objet une
petite corde parfois ouvertes parfois
fermé ses petites cordes possède une
tension comme de minuscules élastique et
elles peuvent vibrer
une corde de guitare peut vibrer selon
différents modes des harmoniques
de même les petites cordes peuvent
vibrer de différentes façons une vague
de vagues
trois vagues et ainsi de suite
et chaque façon de vibrer se comporte à
notre échelle comme une particule
différente lorsqu'on réalise les calculs
on découvre notamment que certaines
cordes se comportent comme des photons
et mieux encore certaines comme des
gravitons en partant du seul principe
que les particules sont de toutes
petites cordes avec une tension on
explique déjà pourquoi il existe
différents types de particules et on
prédit naturellement l'existence du
gravitons décrivant la gravité à
l'échelle quantique
on souhaite désormais comprendre la
façon dont ses cordes évolue dans
l'univers
pour cela on va reprendre les principes
de nos modèles actuels imaginons qu'on
lance un électron sur une cible
l'électron se propage comme une onde et
lorsqu'il atteint la cible
on ne peut pas prédire à l'avance la
position où il va se matérialiser à
l'échelle des particules une même
expérience peut donner plusieurs
résultats différents on peut simplement
prédire la probabilité d'observer tel ou
tel résultat est l'objectif de la
physique à cette échelle est de
déterminer ses probabilités l' approche
mathématique pour déterminer la
probabilité d'observer un résultat
revient à considérer tous les scénarios
possibles qui mène à ce résultat
en même temps on additionne toutes les
trajectoires mais également toutes les
interactions possibles par exemple un
électron peut émettre un photon puis le
réabsorbé ou deux photons voire trois
dans tous les scénarios qu'on
comptabilise on décide manuellement
d'autoriser tel ou tel type
d'interaction pour reproduire ce qu'on
observe dans la réalité et en
additionnant tous ces scénarios on
obtient la probabilité voulu
en théorie des cordes l'approché de la
même mais les particules ne sont plus
des points
ce sont des cordes un point trace une
trajectoire au cours du temps mais une
corde trace une surface et pour décrire
l'évolution d'une corde de façon
probabiliste comme en physique quantique
on va considérer toutes les géométries
possible qu'elle peut tracer au cours du
temps elle peut suivre une certaine
trajectoire vibrer d'une certaine façon
mais également se dédoubler ce qui
revient à émettre une particule où se
recombiner ce qui revient à réabsorber
la particule formant une géométrie avec
un trou en comptabilisant toutes les
géométries possible on inclut
automatiquement les interactions en
théorie des cordes
plus besoin de les ajouter manuellement
de plus les interactions dans le modèle
standard était locale l'émission d'un
photon par exemple se faisait
instantanément mais en théorie des
cordes les interactions sont désormais
continu la particule n'est pas émise
instantanément mais progressivement ceci
permet d'éviter les valeur infinie et
absurde qu'on obtenait lorsqu'on tentait
d'inclure le graviton dans le modèle
standard
ainsi la théorie des cordes prédit non
seulement l'existence du gravitons
mais elle nous permet également de
comprendre la façon dont il interagit
avec les autres particules et donc de
décrire la gravité quantique
[Musique]
jusqu'ici la théorie semble très
prometteuse
elle explique pourquoi il existe
différents types de particules
elle prédit qu'elles peuvent interagir
et elles incluent une description
quantique de la gravité mais
malheureusement à ce stade le modèle
présente trois problèmes premier
problème toutes les cordes se comportent
comme des bosons comme le photon ou le
gravitant dans la réalité il existe une
autre catégorie de particules les
fermions comme les électrons ou les
quark
mais pour l'instant notre modèle n'en
prédit aucun deuxième problème
l'une des particules prédites par la
théorie est ce qu'on appelle un tachyon
sa masse semble être un nombre
imaginaire la racine carrée d'un nombre
négatif
il s'agit d'une absurdité c'est un
problème mathématique qu'il faut''
éliminés enfin troisième problème notre
espace-temps possède quatre dimensions
trois dimensions des espaces et une de
temps
mais cette théorie ne semble fonctionner
que dans un univers à 26 dimension
à ce stade la théorie des cordes semble
très loin de décrire notre univers pour
remédier à ces problèmes
on va pousser la théorie un peu plus
loin afin d'inclure les fermions dans
notre modèle l'idée est d'ajouter des
szpiner sur les cordes
c'est l'ingrédient mathématiques qui
permettait déjà de décrire les fermions
dans le modèle standard
ce seul ajout ajouter des szpiner sur
les cordes permet de régler deux
problèmes le modèle prédit maintenant
l'existence de fermions il ne prédit
plus l'existence du tachyon la particule
qui posait problème
cette théorie plus complète et baptisé
théorie des supercordes en effet
maintenant que l'on a ajouté des szpiner
la théorie présente une symétrie
fondamentale entre les fermions et les
bosons d'une certaine façon elle prédit
qu'il y aurait autant de bauzon que de
fermer on sait ce qu'on appelle la
supersymétrie
[Musique]
qu'en est il du troisième problème avant
d'inclure la supersymétrie les
mathématiques requérait un univers à 26
dimension désormais la théorie des
supercordes requiert un univers à
dimensions 9 10 passes et une de temps
malheureusement ce troisième problème
n'est pas réglé encore une fois la
théorie ne semble pas coller à notre
univers qui possède seulement quatre
dimensions
pourtant jusqu'ici le modèle semblait
très prometteur faut-il l'abandonner
pour autant si elle existe ou seraient
ces six dimensions manquantes
une possibilité est que notre univers ne
soit qu'une tranche tridimensionnel d'un
super univers plus vaste à neuf
dimensions
une autre possibilité serait que les six
dimensions qu'on n'observe pas son
recroquevillée sur elle-même pour
comprendre
imaginons une fourmi qui se déplace sur
une paille
la paille à deux dimensions la fourmi
peut marcher d'avant en arrière et de
gauche à droite sur le pourtour de la
paille mais si l'on s'éloigne
suffisamment le pourtour n'est plus
perceptible ne perçoit que l'une des
deux dimensions
la deuxième celle qui fait le tour de la
paille est tout petit si bien qu'on ne
la perçois pas à cette échelle en
théorie des cordes
on peut supposer un phénomène similaire
notre univers aurait bien neuf
dimensions des espaces mais six d'entre
elles seraient de toutes petites
dimensions recroquevillée sur elle même
si bien qu'on ne les voit pas notre
échelle cette hypothèse peut paraître un
peu douteuse
est il raisonnable de supposer
l'existence de dimensions qu'on
n'observe pas
mais il se trouve que l'existence de
dimensions supplémentaires est une
question très intéressante qui propose
des phénomènes que l'on pourrait
observer par exemple on peut imaginer
une particule sans masse qui se déplace
à la vitesse de la lumière
mais en partie à l'intérieur d'une
dimension compacte
[Musique]
de notre point de vue on ne perçoit pas
cette dimension et par conséquent la
particule nous semble plus lente
on observe seulement une partie de son
mouvement total à notre échelle elles
semblent ralenti comme si elle possédait
une masse l'idée de dimensions compactes
supplémentaires propose ainsi un
mécanisme plutôt simple par lequel
certaines particules pourraient se
manifester avec une masse très
importante
cela dit à l'heure actuelle elle
nécessiterait beaucoup trop d'énergie
pour qu'on puisse les créer dans nos
accélérateurs de particules et vérifier
si elle existe ou non la présence de ces
six dimensions supplémentaires en
théorie des cordes autorise également
une gamme beaucoup plus varié de modes
de vibration et donc indirectement une
plus grande diversité de particules
possible de plus il existe une multitude
de façons différentes de recroquevillé
six dimensions et chaque possibilité va
prédire un univers différent où les
cordes peuvent adopter des modes de
vibration différents et donc se
comporter comme des particules
différentes
en choisissant précisément la façon dont
sont compacts eefje les six dimensions
on peut régler notre description pour
qu'elles prédisent les mêmes particules
que celle qu'on observe dans la réalité
cela dit parmi la myriade de
possibilités
on ne sait pas encore pourquoi notre
univers contient les particules du
modèle standard plutôt qu'une autre
possibilité selon certaines hypothèses
encore spéculative
la géométrie de l'univers aurait
peut-être même varier au cours du temps
passant d'une compacte ification à une
autre et les lois de la physique aurait
ainsi pu changer pendant les premiers
instants du big bang
pour conclure la théorie des cordes
reste à ce jour une théorie spéculative
très difficile à vérifier
expérimentalement car les cordes serait
incroyablement minuscule et qui n'est
qu'une approche parmi tant d'autres pour
tenter d'aboutir à la théorie ultime
mais il s'agit tout de même d'un des
modèles les plus prometteurs dont les
retombées ont largement dépassé son
objectif originale les cordes permettent
de décrire la gravité à l'échelle
quantique et ouvre des portes sur
l'étude des trous noirs
elles ont permis de développer de
multiples plans des mathématiques et de
mieux comprendre certains aspects du
modèle standard lui même la théorie des
cordes propose même des candidats de
particules hypothétique comme les
actions pour potentiellement expliqué la
matière noire
cela dit il reste beaucoup de recherches
à faire en particulier les aspects de la
théorie des cordes qui sont les mieux
compris repose sur l'hypothèse de la
supersymétrie qui prédit l'existence de
nouvelles particules qui pour l'instant
ne sont pas détectés il existe des
compactes ification qui pourrait
expliquer qu'on n'observe pas la
supersymétrie mais elle reste très rare
est encore très peu comprise enfin pour
aller plus loin la théorie des
supercordes existe en réalité en cinq
versions différentes qui décrivent
chacune des types d'univers différents
et on peut montrer mathématiquement que
ces cinq théorie ne sont en réalité que
des approximations d'un unique modèle
encore plus complet une théorie
décrivant un univers à onze dimensions
la théorie m
[Musique]